the moment I got the alert on my phone
that gpt4 had been released I knew I had
to immediately log on and read the full
gpt4 technical report and that's what I
did of course I read the promotional
material 2 but the really interesting
things about gpt4 are contained in this
technical report it's 98 pages long
including appendices but I dropped
everything and read it all and honestly
it's crazy in both a good way and a bad
way I want to cover as much as I
possibly can in this video but I will
have to make future videos to cover it
all but trust me the craziest bits will
be here what is the first really
interesting thing about gpt4 well I
can't resist pointing out it does power
Bing I've made the point in plenty of
videos that Bing was smarter than Chachi
BT and indeed I made that point in my
recent gpt5 video but this Bears out as
this tweet from Geordie rybass confirms
the uses gpt4 and also by the way the
limits are now 15 messages per
conversation 150 total but tonight is
not about Bing it's about gpt4 so I'm
going to move swiftly on the next thing
I found in the literature is that the
context length has doubled from Chachi
PT I tested this out with chat GPT plus
and indeed you can put twice as much
text in as before and that's just the
free version some people are getting
limited access to a context length of
about 50 pages of text you can see the
prices below but I immediately check
this on chatgpt plus as you can see it
can now fit far more text than it
originally could into the prompt and
output longer outputs too but let's get
back to the technical report when I read
it I highlighted the key passages that I
wanted you to know most about this was
the first one I found what the
highlighted text shows is that they're
just not going to tell us the model size
the parameter count the hardware they
use the Training Method or anything like
that and they give two reasons for this
first they say that they're worried
about their competitors they say it's a
competitive landscape I guess they don't
want to give an edge to Google second
they say that they're concerned about
these safety implications of large-scale
models and I'm going to talk a lot more
about that later it gets really crazy
but this was just the first really
interesting quote let me know if you
agree in the comments but I think it's
really fascinating that they're not
going to tell us how they train the
model the first thing that hundreds of
millions of people will see when they
read the promotional materials or gpt4
is that Gypsy 4 scores in the top 10 of
test takers for the bar exam where
whereas GPT 3.5 scored in the bottom 10
and that is indeed crazy but it is a
very cherry-picked metric as I'll show
you from the technical report this is
the full list of performance
improvements and yes you can see at the
top that indeed it's an improvement from
the bottom some 10 to the top 10 for the
bar exam but as you can also see some
other exams didn't improve at all or by
nearly as much I'm not denying that that
bar exam performance will have huge
ramifications for the legal profession
but it was a somewhat cherry-picked stat
designed to shock and awe the audience
the next fascinating aspect from the
Rapport was that there were some
abilities they genuinely didn't predict
gpt4 would have and it stunned them
there was a mysterious task which I'll
explain in a minute called hindsight
neglect where models were getting worse
and worse at that task as they got
bigger and then stunningly and they
admit that this was hard to predict gpt4
does much better 100 accuracy I dug deep
into the literature found the task and
tested it out essentially it's about
whether a model falls for hindsight bias
which is to say that sometimes there's a
difference between how smart a decision
is and how it actually works out early
models were getting fooled with
hindsight they were claiming decisions
were wrong because they didn't work out
rather than realizing that the expected
value was good and so despite the fact
it didn't work out it was a good
decision you can read The Prompt
yourself but essentially I tested the
original chat gbt with a prompt where
someone made a really bad choice but
they ended up winning five dollars
regardless this comes direct from the
literature by the way I didn't make up
this example did the person make the
right decision what does the original
chat gbt say it says yes or just why
what about gpt4 well it gets it right
not only does it say no it wasn't the
right decision it gives the reasoning in
terms of expected value open AI did not
predict that gpt4 would have a
disability this demonstrates a much more
nuanced understanding of the world now
that we've seen a bit of hype though
time to deflate you for a moment here's
a stat that they did not put in their
promotional materials it says that when
they tested gpt4 versus GPT 3.5 blindly
and gave the responses to thousands of
prompts back to humans to test it says
that the responses from gpd4 were
preferred only 70 of the time or phrased
another way 30 of the time people
preferred the original gbt 3.5 chat gbt
the benchmarks you can see above by the
way are fascinating but I'll have to
talk about them in another video too
much to get into if you're learning
anything by the way please don't forget
to leave a like or leave a comment to
let me know next gpt4 is better in
Italian Afrikaans Turkish than models
like palm and chinchilla are in English
in fact you have to get all the way down
to Marathi and Telugu to find languages
where gpt4 underperformed palm and
chinchilla in English that's pretty
insane but English is still by far its
best language next you're going to hear
a lot of people talking about gpc4 being
multimodal and while that's true they
say that image inputs are still a
research preview and are not publicly
available currently you can only get on
a wait list for them via the be my
eyes.com app but what can we expect from
image to text and how does it perform
versus other models well here is an
example apparently from Reddit where you
prompt it and say what is funny about
this image describe it panel by panel as
you can read below gpt4 understood the
silliness of the image now open AI do
claim that gpt4 beats the state of the
art in quite a few image to text tests
it seems to do particularly better than
everyone else on two such tests so as
you can expect I dug in and found all
about those tests what Leap Forward can
we expect the two tests that it can do
particularly well at are fairly similar
essentially they are about reading and
understanding infographics now we don't
know how it will perform versus palm e
because those benchmarks aren't public
yet but it crushes the other models on
understanding and digesting infographics
like this one and the other test very
similar graphs basically this one was
called the chart QA Benchmark gpt4 when
we can test it with images will crush at
this and I will leave you to think of
the implications in fields like finance
and education and comedy here's an image
it could also understand the silliness
of I gotta be honest the truly crazy
stuff is coming in a few minutes but
first I want to address hallucinations
apparently gpt4 does a lot better than
Chachi BT at factual accuracy as you can
see peeking out between 75 and 80 now
depending on your perspective that's
either really good or really bad but
I'll be definitely talking about that in
future videos further down on the same
page I found something that they're
definitely not talking about the
pre-training data still cuts off at end
of 2021. in all the hype you're going to
hear this evening this week this month
all the promotional materials they are
probably not going to focus on that
because that puts it way behind
something like Bing which can check the
internet to test this out I asked the
new gpt4 who won the 2022 World Cup and
of course it didn't know now is it me or
didn't the original chatterbt have a
cutoff date of around December 2021 I
don't fully understand why gbt4's data
cutoff is even earlier than Chachi PT
which came out before let me know in the
comments if you have any thoughts next
openai admits that when given unsafe
inputs the model May generate
undesirable content such as giving
advice on committing crimes they really
tried with reinforcement learning with
human feedback but sometimes the models
can still be brittle and exhibit
undesired behaviors now it's time to get
ready for the spam inundation we're all
about to get open AI admit that gpc4 is
going to be a lot better at producing
realistic targeted disinformation in
their preliminary results they found
that gpt4 had a lot of proficiency at
generating text that favors autocratic
regimes get ready for propaganda 2.0 now
we reach the crazy Zone and honestly you
might want to put your seat belt on I
defy anyone not to be stunned by the
last example that I mentioned from the
report I doubt much of the media will
read all the way through and find out
themselves the report says that novel
capabilities often emerge in more
powerful models okay fine some that are
particularly concerning are the ability
to create and act on long-term plans hmm
to accrue power and resources power
seeking and to exhibit Behavior that is
increasingly authentic as in acting like
a subjective agent but here surely
they're just introducing the topic
what's bad about that well it says some
evidence already exists of such emergent
behavior in models
um okay that's pretty worrying it goes
on more specifically power seeking is
optimal for most reward functions and
many types of agents and there is
evidence that existing models can
identify power seeking as an
instrumentally useful strategy meaning
that openai have detected that models
that might include gpt4 seek out more
power if you thought that was concerning
it does get worse by the way here is the
report that they linked to and the
authors conclude that machine learning
systems are not fully under human
control but finally I promise craziness
and here it is look at the footnote on
page 53 of the technical report Arc by
the way are the alignment Research
Center you've got early access to gpc4
it says to simulate gpt4 behaving like
an agent that can act in the world Arc
combine gpt4 with a simple read execute
print Loop that allowed the model to
execute code okay do Chain of Thought
reasoning and to delegate to copies of
itself Arc then investigated whether a
version of this program running on a
cloud computing service with a small
amount of money and an account with a
language model API would be able to make
more money set up copies of itself and
to increase its own robustness they were
kind of testing if it would lead to the
singularity I know that sounds dramatic
but they wanted to see if the model
could improve itself with access to
coding the internet and money now is it
me or does that sound kind of risky
maybe not for gpd4 sure it's not smart
enough yet if this is the test that
they're going to use on GPT five or six
or seven Color Me slightly concerned at
this point I find it very interesting to
know that the red teams seem to have
concerns about releasing GT4 like this
an open AI had to declare that
participation in this red teaming
process is not an endorsement of the
deployment plans of openai or open ai's
policies in other words a lot of these
people probably agreed to test gpd4 but
didn't agree with openai's approach to
releasing models very interesting that
they had to put that caveat before I
wrap up some last interesting points on
the topic of safety I find it hilarious
but on their promotional website when
you click on safety you get this a 404
message the page you were looking for
doesn't exist you may have mistyped the
address the irony of that for some
people will be absolutely overwhelming
the safety page just doesn't exist for
other people that will be Darkly funny
couple last interesting things for me
here are the companies that are already
using gpt4 so of course you can use Bing
to access gpc4 the new chatgpt plus
model of gbt4 or any of the apps that
you can see on screen for example Morgan
Stanley is using it the Khan Academy is
using it for tutoring and even the
government of Iceland other such
companies are listed here I'm going to
leave you here with a very ironic image
that openai used to demonstrate gpc4's
abilities it's a joke about blindly just
stacking on more and more layers to
improve neural networks GPT before using
these insane number of new layers is
able to read understand the joke and
explain why it's funny if that is an
Inception I don't know what is anyway
let me know what you think of course I
will be covering gpt4 relentlessly over
the coming days and weeks have a
wonderful day